imagine how good you'd be at something
you loved if you're winning at something
that you hate committing to decisions
that you feel drawn toward making often
makes you feel nervous changing a job or
leaving a relationship or moving to a
new city it's often hard to let go of
the fear his justification is that you
absolutely can because if you're not
happy right now you're not risking
anything in any case what's the worst
that could happen you leave a job that
you hate to take a chance on one that
you love fail and still have the one
that you hate there to go back to that's
still a success in fact it's more than a
success because you closed the loop that
you had in your mind that was ramping up
anxiety cost for ages and ages in the
back of your mind and you don't need to
worry about it anymore and this is the
difference in life between playing to
win and playing to not lose how do you
know when to give up the good for the
great how would you even know what good
and great are if you're succeeding at
something that you hate imagine how
amazing you'd be at something that you
loved